Do you feel like it's a backlash or do you feel like you're violating people's privacy?
Do you feel like you're adequately portrayed?
'Cause I wanna wonder about the person who actually created this thing.
Yeah, I mean a lot of stuff happened along the way.
I think, you know, there were real learning points and turning points along the way in terms of building things.
You know, it really went from this position very early on where we were just in this college dorm room...
...to we moved out to California. It was a few friends and me.
And, you know, it just kind of had this project feel for a while...
...and there was this real turning point when companies started trying to buy the company for a huge amount of money.
And, you know, I tell you, kinda get my friends together...
...and we had to decide what was it that we really cared about and what was it that we wanted to do.
And, you know, we decided not to take those offers.
And to me, a lot of that decision was that,...
...what we wanted to do and what we wanted to spend, you know, a big part of our lives doing...
...was just continuing to push and kind of build products that help people share information,...
...build products that help people stay connected.
And that's really what we're spending our time doing.
And, you know, I think there's just been a lot of space between that early stuff and where we are now.
If I knew what I knew now then, then I hope I wouldn't have made those mistakes.
But I can't go back and change the past.
I can only do what we think is the right thing going forward.